fête de la musique beaucoup plus calme
cette année la mairie de lille a
interdit les sonorisations dans le
centre ville côté restaurant la musique
sera autorisé à l'intérieur mais pas en
terrasse une mauvaise nouvelle pour les
bars les cafés et les restaurants qui
subiront des conséquences économiques
pour justifier ce choix la mairie
explique que la fête de la musique avait
pris des allures de rave party causant
parfois des désagréments pour les
riverains a eu des débordements
considérable on avait 300 personnes un
bruit absolument effroyable des
riverains qui n'en pouvait plus et ça ça
on n'en veut plus une pétition a été
lancée sur internet pour que la
municipalité revienne sur cette décision
alors les choses en main oui mais à sa
race déjà pendant le coc vide les
empêcher les rassemblements là il aurait
dû organiser pour pas généré les
riverains elle aurait dû dans ces cas-là
organisé un concert quelque part on
faire quelques semaines le bras séculier
pour que les gens puissent s'amuser
quand même écouter dame n'est pas quand
même un bon jeu tout à fait d'accord
avec martine aubry pour ce coup là on a
fait de la musique ça saoule tout le
monde c'est là c'est une forêt
c'est le bordel dans les rues d'alger
sila pardon c'est pas l'arabe a choisi
de toi ça te faire plaisir tu sors dans
les rues ça un vrai bordel c'est
dégueulasse et la dignité dans le col du
brünig un musicien talent
nous avons un soir dans l'année en
semaine tout seul tout ce merdier c'est
dégueulasse oh pardon c'est quoi le truc
pour qu'on la pousse à quoi mais avant
il y avait un truc formidable
chérif
à la 89e qui font du bruit c'est
n'importe quoi c'est toi tu vas dormir
peut-être qu'ils bossent pas demain à
moi je bosse demain
[Applaudissements]
ils pas des bouquins je t'attendais
c'est la fête de la musique ce soir
c'est vraiment le débat du jour hier
certaines villes si vous nous rejoignez
qui disent 'voilà by wire il
ya dans les rues
diffusion de musique interdite c'est à
dire que je peux
sk on ait l'impression d'arriver dans le
débat
un texto pour son dîner
je vous dirais l'a été quand vous serez
on serait vraiment animateurs
comprendrait qu à 19h50 diatta souvent
des gens qui arrivent qui ne servent pas
de compassion pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent à rien voilà on vous aurait
qu'un jour
vous devrez 15 ans de carrière avoue
pourrait me donner des conseils des
caisses noires à 15 en carrière pour
envoyer un texto en direct pendant
l'émission tu dois alors je vous dire
pourquoi j'ai été souvent je regarde et
je parle avec le producteur d'émissions
à nordine slimani mito vocation de
répondre à quelqu'un pourra changer ton
fils quelques pas du tout je vais vous
dire la vérité ça m'a mis mais c'est mon
ami léo qui m'a écrit merci voilà ce qui
nous regarde voilà d'accord alors oui
alors tiens qu'est ce que tu veux toi
moi je
veux rien mais je suis d'accord avec
mathieu
la fête de la musique est devenue un
grand n'importe quoi ça tire sans doute
une bonne initiative mais aujourd'hui on
a des concerts improvisés de janvier
alors laisse même pas ils savent ni
chanter ni jouer de la musique et ça
j'aime profondément les riverains le bx
volume c'est le bruit c'est la nuisance
principal le moins fait souffrir les
gens on met donc je suis d'accord à 22h
on est un tout
c'est en ville et 77 en ville il ya des
gens âgés qui dorment plus tôt on
n'arrête plus tôt bravo lille ou alors
qu'il passe un casting ces gens que vous
êtes des gros et gris de la société bad
et au delà le truc c'est que déjà on
sort du coc vis de ça veut dire ça fait
trop de mal à personne âgée sache que l
on envie de voir bien sûr elle a envie
d'une rave party sous leurs fenêtres
ne sais pas d'où elles à 17h à pardonner
s'élève à 17 heures à kelly entre par
les 17 caisses qu'elle s'en sert ehpad
alors
bonne odeur n'est pas dans mon lit vous
avez parlé avec moi je pense que vous
êtes levé 17 heures ce que j'ai une
équipe à son essayer de vous joindre
jusqu'à 16h30 c'était eux ont appelé mon
sens pas dans mes priorités de mon
carnet d adresses
web et donc l'émission n'est pas votre
priorité l'émission est ma priorité ça
que je suis là tous les scénaristes
grande foule vous appeler jusqu'à 16h30
content j'ai voulu la merde parce qu'ils
veulent que je trouve un déguisement de
shakira chez moi c'est déjà c'est le
bazar je trouve
les équipes voulaient des costumes
gratuits notre part
bien élevé oui allez rire alors il ya
des personnes qui souffrent de solitude
et qui sont bien contents qu'il y ait un
peu de vie un peu de joie ont été
confinés comme un radical il a eu
l'occasion de faire la fête non mais
sérieusement ça gêne qu'il s'agit d'un
message qu'il a créé une occasion de
chanter toi arrêté avec
nous a laissé le pouvoir à laisser sa
vie la mère est un droit de rien faire
est interdite il ya tout le temps eu la
fête de la musique en plus symbolique
cette année c'est les 40 ans 40 ans de
la fête de la musique est là les mecs où
on n'a plus droit de faire dans les rues
de même il ya des artistes qui aiment
bien aller chanter la fête de musique
dès le sien qui veut dire la rue reliant
une heure je suis jusqu'à minuit et une
heure du matin après c'est terminé on
passe à autre chose s'est pas tarie
régime c'est une règle géante avec des
débats
je veux dire quoi aimer un des
municipalités qui sont et qui trouve la
faille comme ça qu'ils disent quoi ils
ont passé de policier a pas cette
paysanne en fait pour surveiller
toujours avant il y avait de la police
maintenant y'a pas assez de police donc
qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant on
interdit comme ça en étant qu'il n'y a
pas de rassemblement et on ferme pendant
que les gens se battent et des abris les
gens servir sa cause à deux manades
fêter la musique ça c'est des casseurs à
ce moment là il faut pas manifester
parce qu'il ya des casseurs n'ont rien
fait
les feux d'artifice du 14 juillet voit
mal m dans tous les sens jorick dormir
a vraiment
gatland 40 ans
il est désagréments ça se canalise moi
je pense qu'il faut pas du tout
interdire il faut juste que je suis est
absurde d'avoir interdit de la part de
la municipalité s'est complètement
démago c'est juste pour flatter les
vieux voilà et c'est dommage il faut
faire il faut faire ça pour les jeunes
ils ont besoin de sortir et en besoin de
s'amuser il n'y a pas que des règles
aussi des artistes des musiques de
chants exonère la nécessaire
pour tous les goûts bien sûr et voilà et
en plus ça fait exactement ça permet
aussi le business de démarrer tout et
brassens et ses traits c'est très
positif et ça fait d'avoir
[Rires]
le castaldi
il peut dormir au milieu de
ça va
on a vraiment une tête du gars qui
je vous dis croise les bus n'a fait
microsoft mais arrêtez arrêt temporaire
tu démarres l'émission talent est ouvert
du navire demander quel jour on est là
c'est un quelle journée on est mardi
bonne bouffe on
est quand même le seul gars qui est
hyper heureux de te la balle au long de
la semaine
tu as vu chéri quand il m'a t on
[Rires]
il ya des gens ont voulu piéger les
maris
partis achats l'ariège fédéral bien que
tu m'avais quand je dis moi où la balle
a ouais ça percute là-dedans roche est
une patate là c'est ça que
je bouffe tout à l'égout d'un débat en
fait ils veulent pas interdire la
musique ils veulent interdire la musique
amplifiée donc ils veulent interdire les
grosses enceintes dans la rue ils
veulent un gens puissent se reconnecter
cyril valent à interdire la musique non
ils veulent tous les gens se reconnecte
avec les vrais artistes qui jouent des
vrais 0 il ya nous paraît molle personne
si ben ali j'ai demandé à faire de la
flûte de pan et
d'enceintes qui sont mises bout-à-bout
et donc c'est une énorme rêve party
géante on entend tout et on n'entend
rien la fois et pour ceux qui veulent du
gros son et aller dans des
établissements de nuit type le rambo
tous les bars et les restaurants sont
ouverts jusqu'à 2 heures du matin parce
qu'on rambo la musique est importante a
bien évidemment regrettable car
évidemment c'est vrai c'est pour séduire
la musique cesser voilà c'est tu fais
pas tu fais passer une émotion d'accord
bon bien sûr attendent enfin quand même
ça ça parait la base non mais on ne lui
impose pas en voir au robot va d'abord
au premier étage ont fait rencontre on
va au deuxième étage une intervenante
c'est sexy et quand elle pourra compter
sur
[Rires]
nous et sur le toit terrasse sur le toit
c'est pourquoi on dérange pas des
riverains au maroc mali revient
n'arriverait allez vous voulez donner
votre avis là-dessus vous tout
franchement non
mais ça m'intéresse pas vous devenez
problématique à dire non mais moi aussi
j'espère que tu seras 22 heures chez toi
qu'elle ferait bien sûr ans qu'on ne
voit pas dans la rue ce soir à tous elle
apprend vite cependant
elle l'a fait déjà dimanche soir
pas toi tu sais plus quoi faire pour
demeurer
bien at il appelé
dimanche est la loi de faire chier tout
le monde dimanche
dans un lieu où elle n'a personne
contrairement à vous c'était un lieu
privé et moi je vais vous dire si un peu
alors que jamais tu y étais dans un lieu
privé n'est pas allée
bien dans la cité des marques qu'ils ont
fait est que la musique y est meilleure
dans la musique c'est populaire à 8
médiacrates surveillance et gratuit
parce que tu es démago mais
j'aurais dit ata ma pauvre fille scout
et démago alors sa tenue c'est à lui que
vous avez c'est gratuit c'est populaire
en fait
c'est blanc d'état plein d'oseille
qu'est ce que tu penses et sa vie ah bon
c'est vrai parce que dans ces
îles il n'est pas blindé les
débrouillards exactement échec
mais c'est pas bon il ne paye pas la
bouteille d'eau mais non c'est pas le
problème dans son mètre carré se blinder
[Rires]
la bouteille non mais moi c'est pas
pareil moche que je connais bien le
maire enfin je suis une pdc je connais
bien le maire de mykonos ça veut dire
quoi ces annexes alors oui c'est à face
à
une [ __ ] d'état civil
car je voulais acheter un petit
pied-à-terre là bas oui j'aimais
beaucoup donc avait des terrains tout ça
dont je vais rencontrer le maire
guettait même temps que qu'une sommité
entre guillemets
mais colas vous êtes connu en tant que
chroniqueur ou en tant que chroniqueur
chaque ville chaque île à peu sa star il
ya veille avait berne pour parrot c'est
donc mykonos vous les voulez de leurs
minéraux mais julie une égérie voilà
exactement donc c'est vrai que le maire
voulait faciliter un peu l'axé pour moi
l'accès à un terrain
j'ai pas acheté finalement d'accord
voulu me faire payer mais
mais du coup richard la bâche qui la
musique je connais des conseillers
municipaux jeu free ya que des deux
garçons et je suis là je suis chaud oui
oui j'aime bien pied sur l'île d'accord
si tu verras si tu viens avec moi non
mais non ça tu verras que c'est le seul
endroit au monde parce que pour le reste
est une énorme star et pas moi mais
c'est le seul endroit où si tu viens
avec moi tu marches à mettre derrière et
tu verras ce que c'est d'être avec
quelqu'un de puissant
[Rires]
je ne parle pas aux grecs